I'm super excited to take a look at this
today it's a paper written by Ellen
Turing in 1950 and it's called Computing
machinery and intelligence in it Alan
Turing talks about the imitation game
for the first time which has come to me
known as the Turing test it's a famous
idea in computer science and you'll hear
it mentioned often but until now I had
never actually read the original paper
where it was explained by Alan Turing
himself and I'm glad that I finally did
I think anyone interested in artificial
intelligence would benefit from reading
the original paper so let's take a look
at it Turing starts off by considering
the question can machines think but
figures that actually that question is
way too ambiguous the words machine and
think are too ambiguous to Define and
instead he comes up with a game the
imitation game which he thinks will be
equivalent to asking if machines can
think the next paragraph surprised me
it's the first mention of what this
imitation game is but there's no robots
involved yet it is an interrogator
trying to tell the difference between a
man and a woman I don't think that's the
kind of game you would see included in a
scientific paper these days he says the
game is played with three people a is a
man d a woman and C is the interrogator
the interrogator stays in a room apart
from the other two the object of the
game for the interrogator is to
determine which of the other two is the
man and which is the woman in order to
tell this difference the interrogator
could apparently ask questions such as
will X referring to one of the unknown
participants please tell me the length
of his or her hair this communication
would ideally be written so that the
tones of voice don't give anything away
the man is working to deceive the
interrogate data by imitating a woman
whereas the real woman is working to
help the interrogator make the right
identification now here is the important
part where the game evolves we now ask
the question what will happen when a
machine takes the part of participant a
the man in this game will the
interrogator decide wrongly as often
when the game is played like this as he
does when the game is played between a
man and a woman these questions replace
our original can machines think there
are two ways that this can be
interpreted one is the literal
interpretation where the man is replaced
by a machine but nothing else about the
game changes meaning that the machine
has now taken over the man's role of
pretending to be a woman in this version
of the game we have a man trying to
convince an interrogator that he is a
woman competing again just a machine
that is doing the same and trying to see
which one can imitate a woman better
this is a bit of an odd question and
throws the game into the complicated
world of gender identity and expression
but it is the most literal
interpretation of turing's words the
benefit of interpreting the game like
this is that it disguises the
participation of the machine the
interrogator just thinks they are trying
to tell the difference between a man and
a woman and they don't know that
machines are involved at all so they are
less biased and less on the lookout for
questions that would trip up a machine
but this isn't the standard
interpretation of turing's words the
more popular understanding is that when
Turing says that participant a is
replaced by a machine it is assumed that
the goal of the game also changes it's
no longer about pretending to be a woman
but is about pretending to be a human
full stop the interrogator is no longer
picking between male and female for the
participants instead they are choosing
between machine and human this
interpretation seems to be more in line
with comments that Turing later makes
about ways to compare humans and
machines things go totally off the rails
in this next section where a touring is
trying to define the requirements to
enter a machine into the game he seems
to be a little bit worried that a team
of Engineers will say they've made a
machine but actually just enter a human
that they made into the competition and
so I just have to read you this next
part he says one might for instance
insists that the team of Engineers
should be of all one sex this would not
really be satisfactory for it is
probably possible to rear a complete
individual from a single cell of the
skin say of a man to do so would be a
feat of biological technique deserving
of the highest praise but we would not
be inclined to regard it as the case of
constructing a thinking machine this
prompts us to abandon the requirement
that every kind of technique should be
permitted so you're allowed to enter a
machine that you make but you can't
clone yourself or make a baby and enter
that he settles on saying that only
digital computers will be allowed to
take part in our game he says there are
already a number of digital computers in
working order the digital computers in
1950 still looked nothing like the
digital computers that we know today but
he says he's not asking whether the
computer is available at present would
do well but whether there are imaginable
computers which would do well and now we
get to the real juicy part of this paper
Ellen during first shares his own
opinion on the matter he says that he
believes that in about 50 years time
which would be about the year 2000 it
would be possible to program computers
to play the imitation game so well that
an average interrogator would not have a
more than 70 chance of making the
correct identification after five
minutes of questioning he believes that
the original question can machines think
is too meaningless to deserve discussion
but that by the end of the century one
will be able to speak of machines
thinking without expecting to be
contradicted large language models that
we have now like chechi PT might be the
kind of thing that Alan Turing was
trying to imagine would succeed at his
imitation game and I think he did a
pretty good job of estimating what it
would be able to do but his second point
that by around the year 2000 people
would consider machines thinking I don't
think has come true yet chat gbt might
do well at the imitation game but I
don't agree with turing's point that
that would mean that humans would then
consider it thinking in fact what we've
really seen is that we continuously move
the goal posts for what we consider a
thinking machine to be able to do I
don't think that for us now being able
to mimic human speech in an
interrogation would be enough my guess
is that we don't ever want to consider
machines thinking and so as they
approach any arbitrary test that we put
before them we'll come up with a new one
that is more difficult and that we
consider to be more human Turing doesn't
really have a lot of evidence that he
can present to back up his claim that he
thinks a machine will be able to do well
at his imitation game so instead he
tries to imagine every possible point
someone could have to try and say that
machines will never think or that
machines will never do well at this game
to do this Turing has to put himself in
the shoes of people who don't believe in
his work in the same way that he does
and it's pretty impressive that he's
able to do this he comes up with nine
objections the first one is okay maybe
you can make an impressive machine but
it will never be able to think because
thinking is a function of a human's
Immortal Soul during his is not so
impressed with this argument and
basically says that if God is Almighty
he can give a soul to whoever or
whatever he wants to he could give a
soul to an elephant or he could give a
soul to a machine okay but what if this
is all too Dreadful to think about and
we don't want to know about it
the heads and the sand objection in a
kind of cold response to this Turing
says I do not think that this argument
is sufficiently substantial to require
refutation consolation would be more
appropriate okay but what about the
fundamental limitations of mathematics
in our current understanding of
mathematics there are logical statements
that can lead to contradictions or
paradoxes
given that a digital computer will never
be able to do everything that there will
be some questions to which you will
either give a wrong answer or fail to
give an answer at all since machines are
built upon logical systems they have a
disability to which the human intellect
is not subject Turing says that the
superiority we feel in this area is
actually Just an Illusion that we too
give wrong answers based upon our own
flawed logical systems a pretty strong
objection is the argument from
Consciousness now he has to be pretty
clever to come up with counterpoints to
the subjection because it's claiming
that yeah okay a machine might be able
to write a sonnet for example but until
you can prove that it actually has
understood what it's written well then
that doesn't count as thinking to
satisfy someone who thinks in this way
you would need to prove that the machine
actually did have some kind of deep
understanding of what it was able to
produce this is a problem for humans too
this is why if you write a thesis you
might be asked to do a Viva or an oral
exam where a professor will ask you
questions about your work and you have
to defend why you made the decisions
that you did and prove by answering
questions that you understand your work
Turing writes up one such exam for a
machine and to be honest this looks
really similar to the kind of dialogue
and defense I was able to get out of
chat gbt when I asked it why it made
certain word choices in a poem that it
had generated just like Alan Turing
predicted machines can already do a
pretty convincing job of defending their
work but this still doesn't necessarily
mean that they can think and that they
truly understand it philosophically we
Face a conundrum that none of us have
any evidence that anyone other than
ourselves is thinking but for the sake
of our own individual sanity we have to
assume that other people in the world
can think without us being able to enter
their mind and prove it any questions or
debate around Consciousness are pretty
difficult because there is still a lot
of mystery to it but having done a
pretty decent job at giving some counter
arguments here Turing has the confidence
to go on and then counteract another
difficult objection this one says that
sure you can make a clever machine but
you will never be able to make it do X I
think my favorite part of this whole
paper is the ideas that Turing gives for
what x could be he considers that you
might never be able to make a machine
that can be kind resourceful beautiful
friendly have initiative have a sense of
humor tell right from wrong make
mistakes fall in love enjoy strawberries
and cream make some one fall in love
with it learn from experience use words
properly be subject of its own thought
have as much diversity of behavior as a
human or to do something really new this
is my favorite part of the paper because
considering each of these things in turn
and wondering if a machine could ever be
able to do them is something that I find
really fun and interesting to think
about Turing says it's perfectly
reasonable to expect machines to be able
to make mistakes that even a process of
scientific induction can lead to
airiness results and thinking about the
claim that a machine could not be
subject of its own thought Turing says
that by observing the results of its own
behavior it could modify its own
programs so as to achieve some purpose
more effectively he says these are
possibilities of the near future rather
than utopian dreams number six is lady
lovelace's objection
Ayla Lovelace lived long before Alan
Turing so the part of her that is
represented in this section is not
literally her responding and objecting
to touring rather it is touring
including something that she had written
in her time back when she was working on
the analytical Engine with Charles
Babbage an awesome giant steam-powered
mechanical computer she said of the
analytical engine that it has no
pretensions to originate anything that
it can do whatever we know how to order
it to perform a way to interpret this
could be to say that a machine could
never do anything really new or never
take us by surprise but perhaps it is
very understandable that when Ada
Lovelace wrote this statement she didn't
have much reason to believe that this
would ever be possible her and Babbage
were under no obligation to claim all
that could be claimed we could challenge
this idea by considering that there is
nothing new Under the Sun who can be
certain that original work that he has
done was not simply the growth of the
seed planted in him by teaching or the
effect of following well-known general
principles Turing also notes that
machines take him by surprise with great
frequency argument 7 explores the idea
that you could consider our brain and
nervous system to be continuous whereas
a machine would be discrete and asks can
a discrete State machine built on just
math ever a mimic a brain with complex
neurons Turing thinks it can come pretty
close to doing so argument 8 says that
thinking will look pretty different for
a human and a machine because our
behavior is not based on a rigid set of
rules we think that machines are
governed by laws and we are not
therefore we are better than machines we
might not have rigid rules of conduct or
behavior but we do have the laws of
physics and our bodies are bound by
those in that way you could consider our
bodies a kind of machine and we also
can't guarantee ourselves that we don't
follow some complete laws of behavior
because in the spirit of science you'll
never reach a point where we could say
that we've searched enough and there are
no laws number nine I'd never heard
anyone mention until I read it here in
the paper and it's given plenty of space
here so I'm not sure if that means Alan
Turing thought a lot about it and took
it seriously or what was going on but
number nine is the argument from
extrasensory perception it includes a
line saying that unfortunately the
statistical evidence at least for
telepathy is overwhelming I don't know
exactly what he's referring to with that
but he does seem to consider that his
imitation game don't need to take
telepathy into account he even says this
argument is to my mind quite a strong
one He suggests that to overcome this
you could do something like putting the
competitors into a telepathy proof room
so now that Turing has finished
convincing everyone that machines should
be able to do well at this imitation
game the next big question is how to
make such a machine the section here is
touring at his Visionary best it's him
imagining a way to build a machine and
teach a machine all it knows to be good
at imitating a human this part is
interesting he says that to best imitate
an adult human mind you should consider
three things one is the initial state of
the Mind say at Birth the second is the
education to which it has been subjected
and the third is other experience not to
be described as education to which has
been subjected so then he goes on to
talk about these three stages and how to
replicate them in a machine he says it
would be easier to build a child's mind
and then teach it all that it needs to
know rather than trying to build and
start with a knowledgeable adult mind we
can see parallels here to what might be
the first ideas or mentioning of machine
learning Turing mentions wanting to use
punishments and rewards as a learning
process but that you'd have to ensure
that these are unemotional otherwise the
machine would get pretty demotivated if
you're telling it no all the time
there's an interesting point here that
the machine You're Building should
include a random element in its learning
the random element might help it to have
a process that's more analogous to
Evolution and the random power of
mutations and Randomness is a key
element of modern machine learning
Turing says that we may hope that
machines will eventually compete with
humans in all purely intellectual fields
and I love this last line he says we can
only see a short distance ahead but we
can see plenty there that needs to be
done so much of what Turing is imagining
we've been lucky to already witness and
despite that many of us are no closer to
regarding machines as thinking entities
I wonder if the human Spirit can ever be
put into a test and what kind of test
would satisfy us that a machine had
taken its first steps onto the Continuum
of intelligence let me know in the
comments what ideas you have for a
variant of this test or something else
that would make you really stop and
reconsider What machines mean to you
would you ever feel empathy for one and
would you ever consider it to think
thanks for watching this video and thank
you to my patreon supporters for making
it possible a special shout out to
today's patreon cat of the day Dixie
[Music]